MMM.
Hello and welcome to the second part in native lane.com this course on how to
use the Ip to learn about pronunciation in language like vows.
When we talk about consonants in the context of phonetics,
in the APA,
we don't tend to say the letter B or the consonant B.
Instead,
we distinguish features,
the building blocks that make up consonants.
For starters,
we'll consider three basic features of consonants.
First,
where in your mouth do you make this constant sound?
In other words,
where's the consonant sound coming from in your mouth?
The linguistic term for that is place of articulation.
You articulate the sound somewhere,
so that's the place of articulation.
There are multiple places of articulation that helps us distinguish where the
sound is coming from.
If it involves both of your lips,
like the sound p,
that's going to be a bilabial sound by laypeople,
meaning both lips.
If it involves your tongue against your upper teeth,
that's going to be a dental sound like fun.
If you place your tongue against the back of the gum ridge above your upper
teeth,
that's an alveolar sound like s.
If you run your tongue up from your gum ridge for their back towards your
Palette,
you can make a post alveolar sound like shut and that eventually you'll get to
your palate,
the roof of your mouth that produces a palatal sound like,
yeah.
Further back in your mouth,
you have your Villum that produces a Vilar sound like k inside your throat.
You have a Gladys,
and that produces a glottal sound like the catching your throat in.
Uh,
uh,
we've skipped some places of articulation,
but that's a good start.
That covers where you print out sounds,
but what about how you pronounce them?
That's called the manner of articulation.
If you force air up through your nose,
that's a nasal sound.
So you can put your tongue against your gum ridge,
but force the air up through your nose,
which produces the sound.
And you could momentarily stop the airflow to make a stop or a plosive.
So the sound k is a Vilar sound.
It involves the back of your mouth.
That's its place of articulation and the stopping of air,
which makes it a plosive.
That's its manner of articulation.
Another type of sound is a fricative from Latin meaning to rub that involves the
kind of continuous restricted hissing airflow between your tongue and wherever
you're producing the sound.
Or in the case of the Bilabial fricative between your two lists.
Oops.
So if you close your lips and you produce a fricative sound by letting the air
his through,
you get a Japanese f sound.
If you move your tongue up to your alveolar ridge where you made that nasal
sound [inaudible] and instead let the air continue to pass through your tongue
and gum ridge,
you get the z sound.
Another type or manner of articulation is the approximate,
which includes the glides year and Wa in English.
So there are more manners of articulation just like there were more places of
articulation.
The third feature to distinguish here is voicing,
which involves letting the vocal cords in your voicebox vibrate together,
opening and closing them really fast.
When you do that,
you actually produce a voiced sound instead of a voiceless sound.
Vowels are typically all voiced.
That's where they get their name from,
in fact,
but consonants can be voiceless.
The classic tests to tell a difference between voiced sounds and voiceless
sounds is to put your fingers against your throat.
You'll feel that your throat vibrates whenever you save voiced sound and it
doesn't.
Whenever you say a voiceless sound,
there are sounds that have the same place of articulation and manner of
articulation,
but different voicing only.
For instance,
s and z are pronounced the same way,
at the same place in your mouth,
but is voiceless and voiced.
You can't see it,
but my throat's vibrating.
You can try it for yourself.
Just as with vowels,
we can lay consonants out on a chart by their component features.
This time on the y axis will take manner of articulation on the x axis will take
place of articulation and the z axis will be voiced.
Voiceless pairs.
Since this is two dimensional,
we'll write that as voiceless sound,
comma voiced sound.
For instance,
s Comma,
z in the same place and manner of articulation.
I'll read some basic consonant sounds off to you in this chart so you can hear
them and associate them with the Individual Ipa symbols.
Mm mm,
mm.
But to the,
are you well,
okay.